flags across the capitol are at
half-staff this morning in remembrance
of civil rights icon
john lewis the long-time georgia
congressman passed away friday night
after a battle with pancreatic cancer he
was 80 years old
a great patriot lewis was the last
living speaker at the 1963 march on
washington
where dr martin luther king jr delivered
his i have a dream speech
house minority leader kevin mccarthy was
his friend and colleague
he joins me now congressman it is good
to see you this morning my condolences
good to see you maria thank you and i do
want to
talk about john lewis just for a moment
because he lived such an extraordinary
life with an unbelievable man
at such at a young age he tried to cross
a bridge simply
to give people the right to vote he did
in a peaceful manner and he was beaten
almost to his death i've walked across
that bridge with him before
and when he would tell the story he
would stop at a moment and says i cannot
remember
past beyond this point because they
would beat him and he did it in a
peaceful manner to help change this
nation
that no longer do people our choice
about which bathroom they use or which
counter they eat on or even registering
to vote he
made this nation better and he lived his
life in a manner
that we could all respect and live up to
and he was kind to all
and he i just spoke to him a couple
weeks ago
checking on his health but talking to
him about what's happening in the nation
today
because he did it in a peaceful manner
to help preserve and
actually create a more perfect union i
think a lot can to understand him
and live by his example to make this
nation better
yes thank you for that when when we go
to break after our interview we're going
to show a little clip
of of john lewis which is a beautiful
clip and and something that i know that
our audience will love so stay with us
for that but let me let me get uh
to to the business at hand for our
viewers and you're going back
uh to congress will return to work
tomorrow and
you are looking at a potential next
stimulus package a relief package
what should be in that package
congressman
a number of things should be in that
package but we also have a large amount
of money more than about 1.5 trillion
still out there that we have already
appropriated
that we need to get into this economy
but the things i look for the things we
need to do
we need liability of protection because
these small businesses are questioning
whether they can open again our schools
and others
so let's protect those as we move
forward let's
also look at anytime you're using
federal money it shouldn't
give you a dece de-incentivize the
ability to work we've made a mistake
where we overpaid on unemployment
insurance where now it's hard for people
to come back to work because they're
making more
on unemployment than they can working so
we've got to straighten that out as we
move forward
i would look at places that we could
should prioritize the safety when it
comes to child care
or for our children our teachers inside
schools and then i would look at the
supply chain
if we learn nothing from this not the
lies of china
but bringing those jobs back to america
but also our supply chain itself
not being beholden to china for so much
of our critical
minerals and others let's find a way
that we improve it here
and for our stockpiling i would do that
in a different manner working with
the private sector to stockpile it
so the president would like schools to
open in the fall congressman will there
be money
in this next bill for schools and what
about the states
are are these the priorities right now
for that next bill
well the uniqueness of what we have
right now maria we have more than a
hundred billion dollars
that we've already appropriated that can
go to the states i think we can look at
ways that we can
make that greater flexibility and lots
of times we're finding
when we sent these monies to to these
governors that they've held it up
instead of pushing it down
to the counties in the cities i would
like to see more flexibility
where it goes to the counties and cities
in the place of need we would look at
hospitals if they need more
in the process of where we're going
forward we also have more than 100
billion dollars sitting there
for such a successful program of ppp for
small businesses
that saved millions of jobs now we're
seeing that some states
have to close certain portions is there
a greater need
for small businesses we already have
money sitting there
so could we use the money already
appropriated to solve some of these
problems
sure i understand but you know the the
democrats
are pushing back on the president saying
he wants to open schools
and i wonder how much of this is
politics although you know it is scary
for
parents to say we're going to send our
kids back to school
and we don't know what the situation is
in terms of the coronavirus we're seeing
spikes across the country
here's what president trump told me just
recently when i interviewed him
at the beginning of this pandemic listen
to this
your critics want you to keep it closed
going into the election yeah i do i do i
think it's a it's a
political thing in addition uh i think
they're saying you're putting money
uh business ahead of lives yeah no no uh
i think if the people that want to see
the right thing happen
they agree with me we have to get our
country open you know
it was up to some people let's keep it
closed for a long time
okay a long time and watch the united
states go down the tubes not going to
happen
i mean i guess we are going to be living
with this congressman but can we
actually go back to our normal lives
safely right now given these spikes that
we're seeing across the country
in certain parts of the country you can
nobody wants to send somebody to school
that's unsafe
that's why congress should actually look
at this how can we protect when it comes
to child care
the children in school and the teachers
but what's more important when you look
at these recent studies
you're finding that children can should
not have not kept
their reading their writing and their
math losing more than 30 percent of it
we cannot have a whole generation that's
uneducated
so what we need to do is actually put
that plan together because we've got to
make sure
schools can reopen and that's takes a
responsibility what we're doing now
we're finding even in california where
l.a and san diego say they're not going
to open for the whole year
remember what is happening here with
warp speed we've got
five companies that are in barda that
have a real promise of having a vaccine
could even be this year are the
therapies that are coming forward
tomorrow is going to be better than
today based upon what this
administration been doing
yes look look what's happening to our
cities i know you have a bill right now
to to punish anybody who is taking down
statues
but there is a massive movement across
the country on the other side
of the aisle your colleagues on the left
they want to defund the police
listen to joe biden recently here it is
do we agree that we can redirect some of
the funding
yes absolutely and one of the things
that we also need to be doing
is fundamentally changing the way and
i've been pushing it for years
changing the way we deal with our prison
system
it should be a rehabilitation system not
a
punishment system
well what does that mean congressman
because we are seeing this bail reform
in new york allow criminals back on the
street and that's one of the reasons
crime is skyrocketing what is your
responsibility
as the leader of the gop to get law and
order
back in place in this country
well every american should be scared
right now because what you just showed
the country
was joe biden said yes he is for
defunding the police
you got congresswoman omar who wants to
dismantle
america then you got nancy pelosi who's
allowing him to destroy america from
statues and on
we have a responsibility for rule and
law and for justice
and what we're watching the democrats
doing watch what nancy pelosi just said
the other day she thinks what's
happening is port in portland is a
graffiti
problem no it's a mob problem that is
overrunning
you have people across this nation
scared to death you have young children
being murdered
because what they're doing to the police
department this is wrong
your bill our bill will withhold federal
grants for cities
that do not uphold and protect the
statutes because
the cities have the responsibility for
law and order
not to leave these precincts not to
allow these mobs to rule
our communities we have to stand up to
this
it is scary out there i agree with you
congressman it's good to see you this
morning we certainly will be watching
the developments thanks so much
congressman kevin mccarthy this morning